you know some of you by your children
nice clothes you give them expensive
haircuts you spend $4,000 making sure
their teeth are straight and then you
don't teach them to say thank you and
you raise a highly attractive child
physically who is a complete twit and no
one wants to be around because they have
no manners thank you thank you thank you
that's a good thing to learn to say and
to mean it grateful people are highly
attractive people
they're very attractive we all like to
be around people who are grateful
they're grateful for their job they're
grateful for their spouse they're
grateful for their kids they're grateful
to God they're grateful for opportunity
to live in America they're not entitled
they're not a victim they're not
self-centered they're other centered
grateful people are just highly
attractive people and grateful people
have their own holiday you that are
grateful have your own holiday this is
it it's called Thanksgiving you give
thanks all the time and this holidays
for you this is a holiday that's put in
place by Abraham Lincoln in 1863
specifically according to the
proclamation he wrote out and read that
year specifically that we give thanks to
God Almighty our Heavenly Father that's
what the proclamation says a little hard
to create a revisionist history on that
you read the words that's what it says
so children that are grateful to their
father are highly attractive children
that are grateful to their mother are
highly attractive and when we are
grateful to God for our blessings we are
more attractive hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh